Lên tiếp sự việc người nổi tiếng quan cảo sản phẩm kếm chất lượng khiến người trôi dùng
Hoang Măng, hàng giả hàng kếm chất lượng đang này cảm phủ biến chính các thản thường bài đi từ
Chức tiếp là mạnh lượng để quyền lời và suyện người trôi dùng
Nếu đần nói là không biết cây về ok lột gì, nhưng người có sinh anh vừa chỉ mặt sạ hội
cũng có phải tính chắc quan bà sai lịch thì uống kìm chính vình của gốc chất lượng xa phần
Không phải lần đầu tiên công Trung thất vọc, chức đầy, không loạt nghệ sĩ lớn như lệ sĩ nền ra đồng vân
Bên tập biến quan mình, dính viên vân chào, nằm thương dự như đá phải công khai sĩ lộn khán giả
vì như quán cao lỗ công dục xa phần. Mời đe nhất, như tập bà hoa chất tìm lý tiếng
á kìm tên những kếm gì có tiếng trên bà sau hội, như lệ mùa xí quốc và phạm tròi
Vấn vòng viên quan cao xa tâm kếm chất lượng, của tế hoa đã này chiến bà như sau
về mức xa xíu xe, chí tu mời đến hành đi đồng chế một hú, đi kèm lời quan cao tình vấn lên đến
mình bán ký vị thì mình phải đồng quan ghê nhà mình cũng sẽ dùng. Nhưng quan cao tùa
phòng công dục của hàng loạt lời nổi tiếng đã khiến công dùng giống dây lên quan
nhạc về sự an toàn xe xí quay. Tí tìt thì, tên nhà sáng tạo lộ dùng
kế hoa xí quế lưng đặt lợi ít người tư dùng lên hành đầu. Nhưng có thể tạo ra dại
chỉ bên vấn cho chiến mình và cục đồng.